one of the biggest frustrated in this
entire release the FISA memo drama is
that people just can't seem to pronounce
Devon Nunez correctly no I'm kidding
actually that is a frustration people
calling him Nunez but of course when you
see those typically Spanish names with
an S on the end that's like the
Portuguese version of those names so
it's not Nunez with an N yes Nunez I've
been hearing Nunes - which is seven
words oh yeah yeah it's honestly I think
that's better than new I really do I I
think in some way it is but reasonable
people could disagree about that
no anyway the the reality is that a
fragment of the right is putting all of
their distract from Russia eggs in the
release the memo basket in this sort of
irrational and unhinged way and I've
been skeptical that this memo which I
keep saying over and over again release
it as long as we're being responsible
with classified information I've been
skeptical that the memo would have any
bearing whatsoever on Robert Moeller's
Trump Russia investigation even though
many people on the right seem to think
that when this memo if and when this
memo is released it's going to totally
discredit Robert Moeller Donald Trump's
friends and and allies or staffers a
bunch of people around Trump have said
Trump sees the release of the memo as
possibly a way to get in the way of the
Robert Mulder Trump Russia investigation
if the memo comes out and it really puts
into question Robert Muller's ability to
continue carrying out the investigation
with integrity I will be the first to
tell you that Robert Muller is not a
credible investigator and he needs to be
replaced until that happens every
indication is that Moeller is a credible
and trustworthy investigator but the
problem is that now I'm not even sure if
and when the memo is release released
we'd actually be able to assess the
impact because Devon Nunez who wrote the
memo is accused of altering it before
sharing it with Donald Trump
so the accusation from ranking
Democratic congressman Adam Schiff who's
on the Intel committee is that the
chairman of the House Intelligence wrote
one memo and then sent a different
version
an altered version to Donald Trump the
reasons why he might do this are
numerous now the most benign explanation
which is what Devon knew NASA's team is
saying is that there were a couple words
changed here or there for sort of
logistical or administrative purposes
but that it doesn't actually change the
underlying meaning that's the most
benign explanation it's not the one that
Adam Schiff is saying is the accurate
explanation and it's possible that Nunez
exaggerated the abuses he believes
happened in the first memo and he's
showing Trump a more accurate version
that is less hyperbolic the opposite is
also possible it's possible that Devon
Nunez is showing Trump the more
exaggerated and salacious version in
order to get Trump fired up for one
reason or another I don't know the truth
but the accusation from Adam Schiff
which he tweeted yesterday is discovered
late tonight that chairman Nunez made
material changes to the memo he sent to
the White House
change is not approved by the committee
White House therefore reviewing a
document the committee has not approved
for release supposedly we're gonna hear
tomorrow maybe Friday whether Donald
Trump is or isn't going to release the
memo these allegations might delay the
release of the memo everything could be
delayed significantly we'll see but the
bottom line here is that I believe Adam
Schiff big picture I mean mostly it's
because Nunez has a track record of
doing exactly this type of thing Nunez
had an ethics complaint against him
which was not settled in his favor
ultimately it was dismissed but it was
not settled in his favor regarding the
disclosure of classified information
according to law fair Nunez didn't allow
the FBI and DOJ to look at both his memo
and Adams shifts response because they
say that why would they allow a
committee that's in part investigating
new nests to evaluate his memos it's all
just sort of weird but the big picture
is if you ask me who I believe I believe
Adam Schiff here yeah I'm so sick of
Devin Nunez he's not an honest actor he
was part of the Trump transition - yeah
so I don't know how he can even be on
this committee right now to begin with
you
and then he briefed the subject of the
investigation on the progress of the
investigation
remember when he ran to the White House
yes rolling on based on information that
he got from the White House initially he
said he's gonna back away from the
Russia investigation then he didn't
recuse himself yeah we got this memos
and wasn't even that sort of ambiguously
worded work yes said he would be
stepping away from the investigation
which I mean listen just because you
hear him say I'm stepping away and you
report he's recusing himself he didn't
say he was recusing him yeah
the media thought that he was recusing
himself but really he was taking a week
or two off now he should have gotten his
assignment removed from the House
Speaker Paul Ryan absolutely but that
didn't happen and there have also been
threats to investigate to start a new
investigation on Nunez if he releases
the memo that was earlier on in this
entire thing listen big picture I've
said it before and I will summarize it
in this way
release the memo if it's going to be
done in a safe and responsible way where
what needs to be redacted is redacted do
not be confused about the integrity of
the robert muller investigation based on
allegations in a dubious memo that we've
not yet even seen i guess is my word of
caution you know the democrats have a
memo to oh yes trying to put all of this
in context and point out the the
problems that they have with the Nunez
memo but of course the house is voting
not to release it that's right and
honestly a succeed a cascade of memos is
not the most thrilling thing right now
when we have not only the Trump Russia
investigation itself but sort of like
endless important political issues going
on so let's just figure out if anything
actually concerning took place in terms
of FBI actions let's take it out of the
realm of Trump using it to just
interfere with Robert Malloy's
investigation and let's move on and a
lot of discussion about the memo on the
David Pakman show
subreddit you can participate in those
conversations if you'd like at david
pakman.com slash re d di t
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by brilliant it
brilliants this amazing website that
lets you engage
in fun and interesting problems and
puzzles to learn more about almost
anything related to math science and
engineering the really vibrant community
of over five million members it brings
together expert the experience of
students and educators and professionals
from all over the world and they've
created a really interactive learning
environment and learning in the presence
of an actual community really does make
a difference when you use brilliant you
become part of the community of five
million members who share your curiosity
and your love for math and science and
the community at brilliant actually
supports your learning you build an
emotional connection with the subjects
you're studying because you're
interacting with other people that are
learning the same thing and that's
really what sets brilliant apart from
other educational websites you can get
started right now by signing up for free
at brilliant org slash david pakman and
if you're one of the first 200 people
who visit brilliant org slash david
pakman and sign up you will get 20% off
an annual premium membership if you want
it
that's brilliant org slash david pakman